vocês sabem quantos animais eu já matei
vou contar pra vocês a história mas eu
vou contar desde o começo uma vez quando
eu era adolescente eu saí do colégio e
foi almoçar com a minha família numa
churrascaria
aí eu aceitei uma coxa de frango que o
garçom me ofereceu como eu já tinha
aceitado tantas e tantas outras vezes
só que naquele dia o sabor a textura
alguma coisa naquela coxa de frango não
me agradou
deixando de lado espero que viesse algo
que me pertence mais
e foi o que aconteceu de repente como
uma bigorna cair na minha cabeça eu
percebi que aquilo era parte de um ser
que um dia estava vivo foi morto para me
servir de alimento teve sua perna
arrancada queimada colocado diante de
mim
e coube a mim o veredito final dizer
simplesmente não é bom o suficiente pra
mim essa essa reconstrução da narrativa
de vida da narrativa mental que eu
acabei de contar pra vocês me
desconcertou muito tudo parece tão
gratuito também lógico tão naquele
momento experimentei uma náusea como
nunca tinha sentido na minha vida eu
digo uma náusea tanto no sentido
sartriano existencial quanto no sentido
estomacal mesmo e aí
naquele momento tudo que eu pude fazer
foi cruzar os talheres
só que eu saí do restaurante naquele dia
da churrascaria com a certeza de que eu
jamais votaria comer carne porque eu
senti de algum modo que aquilo
simplesmente era errado não sabe
explicar por que mas então sempre muito
questionador sempre muito cético naquela
época eu queria ser cientista
eu decidi racionalizar tenta entender o
porquê daquele meu choque diante do
pedaço de frango
só que antes de contar pra vocês que eu
descobrir
talvez seja interessante falar como é
que a minha família reagiu diante da
decisão de tirar caiu do cardápio todo
mundo se preocupou especialmente à minha
mãe e minha avó
achavam que o enfraquecer e que vai
definir até a morte de maneira muito
rápida então o único consolo que tinha
era imaginar que não passava tudo de uma
maneira de adolescente de alguma coisa
que logo desapareceria
mas a coisa não passou e não passou
justamente porque eu me esforcei para
entender aquela minha emoção aquele
impacto eu tive na mesa da churrascaria
e eu fui buscar respostas nos livros na
época aliás assim que buscava ainda
buscam respostas dos livros porque já
então eu lia muito e queria ser um
escritor também e eu descobri nos livros
que já no século 6 antes da era comum o
pitágoras aquele mesmo do teorema que
ninguém sabe
ele dizia que nós devemos respeitar os
animais porque havia uma coisa chamada
transmigração de almas ou seja um ser
humano podia morrer renascer reencarnado
um corpo de vaca e de porco e por isso o
respeito demonstrado uma vaca ou um
corpo no fundo no fundo era
potencialmente respeito demonstrado um
ser humano
eu não gostei daquela explicação as
coisas começaram a melhorar quando
encontrei um livro desse sujeito chamado
por filho de abstinência água e zoom
animá-lo da abstinência de comer animais
esse não foi um achado por duas razões
primeiro pra quem estava lá tinha na
escola o exercício de leitura foi muito
instigante
segundo as explicações do por filho me
pareceram mais consistentes mais
racionais advogava que nós devemos
respeitar os animais por aquilo que eles
de fato são seres sensíveis e consciente
e não por aquilo que eles não são
pessoas aprisionadas nos corpos dos
animais
esse foi um texto que me marcou muito
quanto a mim pergunte porquê acidente em
que estado de alma ou demente o primeiro
homem que o fez
tocou o sangue com a sua boca e levou os
seus lábios a cara de uma criatura morta
aquele que pôs à mesa corpos mortos e
feridos e aventurou se chamar de
nutrição os pedaços que um pouco antes
brasil e gritavam moviam se viam como
puderam seus olhos suportar o massacre e
se cortarem gargantas de esfolar o coro
de arrancar um membro de outro membro
como pôde o seu nariz aguentar o fedor
como é quem moon disse não causou
repulsa ao paladar daquele que fez
contato com as feridas de outros e sugou
fluidos e soros de ferimentos mortais
como vocês vêem em algum momento da vida
dele por filho assim como eu experimento
uma recusa terrível diante do gesto
aparentemente banal de se comer carne
eu me senti muito acompanhado me senti
muito feliz porque afinal de contas
encontrou alguém que pensava que nem eu
claro era um sujeito nascido na líbia
mais de 1500 anos atrás tudo bem mas a
isso não importa tinha alguém que
pensava como eu eu continue analisando
aquele momento de revelação que eu tive
diante do tal frango e parei pra
descobrir logo em seguida sem muito
esforço que na verdade aquilo era fruto
era o ápice de um processo inconsciente
que já vem se desenrolando há muito
tempo eu tinha o hábito desde pequeno de
ajudar minha mãe a recolher tratar e
gatos e cães de rua e não suportava ver
os cavalos mal tratados nas ruas da
cidade
eu simplesmente entrava em surto com
algum parente a pescar e voltava da
pescaria traz nos peixes para morrer
sufocado em baldes deixados na varanda
tudo isso pra mim era puro terror mas
por alguma razão não conseguiu estender
essa consideração que os animais que me
serviam de alimento e porque eu não
conseguia nem por qual razão
eu parei pra pensar um pouco e me dei
conta também sem grande dificuldade é
porque simplesmente como os meus bisavós
como os meus avós meus pais eu nasci
imerso na sociedade dentro da qual é
moral matar os animais para comer
assim como é moral criá-los e aprisioná
los para que nos forneçam outros
produtos como leite ovos por exemplo
só que ele um conceito muito importante
tem duas esferas que são bastante
distintas e às vezes as pessoas misturam
a esfera da moral esfera da ética moral
tem a ver com rumores palavra em latim
significa costumes a moral ela é
simplesmente a descrição dos costumes de
uma sociedade sem juízos de valor se
busque entender por que uma sociedade
exerce tais práticas
quais são as razões que motivam aquilo é
uma prática a análise moral uma prática
descritiva
porém quando se fala de outras questões
como o status moral dos animais estupro
genocídio infanticídio impacto ambiental
aborto parece que uma abordagem
meramente descritiva não serve
essas temáticas sugerem uma abordagem
prescritiva ou seja nós estamos falando
aqui do que é certo e do que é errado
tanto no campo da moral quanto no campo
da ética mas as semelhanças param por aí
porque na verdade a ética é justamente a
filosofia da moral
seu estudo e o seu polimento numa
sociedade como a nossa em que é
considerado muito feio julgar
de fato a ética pode parecer um campo
muito muito antipático da filosofia
porque o papel dela é justamente esse é
apontar o dedo com uma determinada
prática dizer isso é bom ou isso é mau
isso é certo ou estou errado ea ética
ela de fato ela aspira trazer preceitos
de conduta que sejam gerais universais e
também imparciais
claro que um homem o ser humano que siga
completamente a perfeita moral
estabelecida pela ética é uma utopia mas
é claro que o que importa o processo o
que importa é esse contínuo aprendizado
e se contido burilamento das nossas
condutas diárias
isso é muito importante bom
existe uma outra coisa que nós temos que
pensar quando se fala de de moral e
ética que é justamente o fato de que
elas operam dimensões diferentes né
a moral ela fala da conduta dos costumes
ela é temporal
ela é prática é ação descrita a ética é
o princípio ela é a regra ela tem
aspiração de ser permanente ela é teoria
é reflexão em essência então a moral
fala como as coisas são a ética diz como
elas deveriam ser
então de fato sempre vive cercado de
pessoas que comiam carne dos animais
pelas mais diferentes coisas
é assim que as coisas são mas aí eu me
perguntei será que elas devem ser assim
e essa foi a reflexão ética que me
acompanhou nas semanas seguintes
aquele episódio na churrascaria eu parei
pra pensar então sobre esse assunto e me
dei conta de que a mera aceitabilidade
de uma prática
logicamente não assegura que ela seja
por si só e automaticamente correta
comer carne e matar animais tudo isso
dentro da minha sociedade é aceito mas
quem garante que isso não é aceito na
minha sociedade no meu tempo e realmente
em condições muito limitadas quem diz
que isso é o bom que isso é o belo que
isso é o correto
então eu sempre tive em volta de mim
pessoas que comem animais e que se
utilizam dos animais e eu parei pra
pensar então sobre esse esse desconforto
que a convivência ter de conviver em um
mundo que tinha idéias tão diferentes
das minhas me causava então eu parei pra
pensar sobre o tamanho do meu erro se eu
estava realmente errado se havia
possibilidade de estar errado e também
comer e também utilizados animais qual é
o tamanho do meu erro ou seja quantos
animais
a pergunta mais básico tinha matado até
aquele momento da minha adolescência eu
parei então para fazer as contas
claro que nunca tinha matado um animal
com as minhas próprias mãos porque a
nossa a moral da nossa sociedade é muito
eficiente em afastar os horrores dos
matadores dos olhos da maioria embora
apesar dessa distância os matadores
operam 24 horas por dia
o tempo todo enquanto nós tocamos nossas
vidas nós trabalhamos nós descansamos e
nós dormimos os matadores estão
funcionando há caminhões e caminhões e
animais são despejados os matadouros
como prisioneiros são despejados nas
portas de campos de concentração e lá
através de verdadeiro processo de
mecanização em verdadeiras linha de
desmontagem de animais nesses animais
são transformados em comida ou seja
havia pessoas que faziam esse serviço
pra mim tudo bem antiga matado nenhum
animal com as minhas próprias mãos mas
quantos animais essas pessoas tinham
matado pra mim
algumas estimativas falam de uma pessoa
que tem o hábito de consumir animais
ela vai consumir até 17 mil animais
longo de uma vida de uns 80 anos
não é preciso ser um grande mestre da
matemática para fazer as contas e ver
que até minha adolescência quando
ocorreu o episódio na churrascaria
deveria ter matado os 1400 animais
esse número e perseguiu 1.400
será que não teria uma justificativa
para isso
será que o fato de se servirem de
alimento por si só não era uma boa razão
não seria uma espécie de mal necessário
então eu fui levado a pensar também
sobre aspectos que às vezes me passaram
batidos
encontrei as minhas pesquisas um
princípio que é muito simples mas ao
mesmo tempo muito eficiente que
basicamente o princípio de que para nós
tentarmos julgar eticamente um ato como
certo ou errado não basta medir quão
felizes e com tristes dos envolvidos sai
dessa ação ou seja
o escrutínio ético e não é simplesmente
colocar dor e prazer e uma balança
exige muito mais por exemplo se uma
pessoa é vítima de estupro
não interessa realmente não interessa
nem um pouco a dose de prazer que o
criminoso obteve através desse ato a
pessoa teve um direito seu violado os
direitos por ninguém
claro que mediu com feliz as pessoas
saírem de uma determinada prática é
muito importante desde que a gente tenha
a certeza de que nenhum direito
essencial foi antes violado
então por isso eu seguir nessa linha de
raciocínio e me dei conta de outro
aspecto muito interessante que segue
exatamente nessa mesma linha que tudo
bem
as pessoas consomem os animais tudo bem
nós temos que considerar mais do que dor
e prazer
mas vamos pensar em direitos mas o que é
o direito jeito basicamente é uma
barreira que protege as outras pessoas
que violarem um direito seu
o melhor dizendo um interesse
fundamental o seu e é justamente a
instituição de um direito que promove
essa barreira
quando tenho interesse esse endereço
está em ameaça eu posso invocar um
direito pra que esse meu interesse
essencial seja preservado
então basicamente essa a questão que eu
me propus a pensar qual a diferença
entre um interesse e uma preferência o
interesse ele é uma necessidade
extremamente básico extremamente
essencial que se não for suprida pode
comprometer gravemente a capacidade
psíquica e física de um indivíduo uma
preferência nada mais é do que uma opção
num cenário de duas ou mais
possibilidades não essenciais e baseado
nisso um princípio ético muito
interessante que é justamente o
princípio ético de que os interesses têm
predominância preponderante
chovem antes das preferências
o meia conta de algo que também não me
pareceu tão complexo
logicamente um animal assim como ser
humano
ele é um ser sensível e não ser
consciente ele quer ter contato com seus
iguais quer dizer se essa autonomia
prática o animal ele quer procurar o
alimento no seu ambiente natural
ele quer ter liberdade ele não quer
sentir dor
ele preza pela própria vida assim como
ser humano
então se eu o ser humano tenho o direito
de ter todas essas minhas capacidades ou
esses meus interesses
melhor dizendo preservados porque o
animal que compartilha comigo da
sensibilidade da consciência necessária
para prezar pela própria vida também não
teria então analisando mais uma vez a
questão de que os interesses são
protegidos por direitos que as
preferências ficou em segundo lugar logo
raciocinei muito bem os animais têm
interesses em comum com os humanos
nós humanos temos o interesse ou seja
necessidade essencial de nos
alimentarmos muito bem mas agora a
escolha da dieta é uma questão de
preferência nessa medida deve pesar mais
inclusive está protegido por um direito
não sofrimento do animal
e foi assim que descobri pesquisando
sobre direitos sobre direitos animais
especificamente que existe uma coisa
chamada veganismo que nada mais é do que
um movimento que se norteia pelo
princípio ético de que o ser humano vivo
sem explorar os animais se utilizar os
animais seja a alimentação seja pra
vivissecção seja para entretenimento
seja para vestuário caça ou qualquer
outro uso que vocês podem imaginar
para o organismo por ser um movimento de
fundamentação ética assim como ética em
si ele é o norte e não um fim em si
mesmo ou seja por mais que seja difícil
ou até impossível nos abstermos
completamente de produtos de origem
animal nessa nossa sociedade que foi
criada que foi erigida sobre forte
exploração animal mais que isso
realmente seja muito difícil nada disso
justifica a nossa nação nós precisamos
nos comprometer é eticamente em
raciocinar sobre essa questão e é por
isso que eu me descobri não acompanhado
somente por um sujeito um neo platônico
nascida mais de 1500 anos descobri pelo
mundo todo há pessoas que já refletiram
sobre essa questão
há pessoas que estão preocupadas com os
direitos animais e vem no organismo um
caminho que eu digo pra vocês pra
encerrar
essencialmente é que todos aqueles que
abominam a crueldade a injustiça a
matança exploração de seres inocentes
deviam analisar 100 escudos o caminho do
organismo nos aponta há quase duas
décadas
eu parei para pensar sobre quantos
animais eu tinha matado até então
descobri que tinha matado muitos animais
sem querer sem mesmo saber que eu tinha
feito isso mas há quase duas décadas
então eu também decidi que não ia mais
matar animais e é realmente muito
importante nós pensarmos que ao
contrário dos outros animais ao
contrário daquele frango que foi servido
como a última porção de carne que eu
experimentei nós seres humanos somos
capazes de raciocínio de escolhas
racionais
então é portanto o que nós arcamos com
as consequências com as implicações
dessa nossa capacidade especialmente em
relação àqueles seres que não têm voz e
que jamais vão ser capazes
de assumir o protagonismo da própria
libertação obrigado